natural-language api can be used to  perform sentiment entity and syntax  analysis on text lets you see how to use  natural language a pair with seizure  first make sure the API is enable in  your project and the service I can exist  to make API calls both are explained in  the cobweb in the video notes  in cloud shell let's create a simple  dotnet console app  and add natural language API nougat  package to the project  open the code or the editor and navigate  to program dot C s we will perform  sentiment analysis on a piece of text  referenced natural language APA library  create language service client  call analyze sentiment on the text get  the sentiment and final print results  to run the app there you go you just  perform sentiment analysis using natural  language API